ÇDas Schwierigste war, ...
... als wir uns damit auseinandersetzen mussten, ...
... dass unsere vierjŠhrige Tochter
allein zum Kindergarten gehen soll.È
ÇDas war eine grosse Herausforderung fŸr mich.
VierjŠhrige Kinder gehen in den USA ...
... nicht allein zum Kindergarten.
Das gibt es einfach nicht!È
ÇMeine Freundin und ich
fuhren gemeinsam in die Ferien ...
... und unterwegs, im Flugzeug,
lernte ich meinen Mann kennen.È
ÇAls ich sie herauskommen sah, ...
... war das meine Chance!
Es war jetzt oder nie!
Einer dieser Momente.
Also nahm ich allen Mut zusammen
und sprach Eli an.
Das war die beste Entscheidung
meines Lebens!È
ÇWir haben wŠhrend vier Monaten ...
... jeden Tag acht bis neun Stunden
im Messenger ...
... miteinander geplaudert.È
ÇJeden Tag, am Telefon und per Messenger, und ...
... es ging so weit, dass ich fand:
Ich muss dich sehen!
Wie kšnnen wir das machen?
Komm nach New York!È
ÇAn diesem Wochenende wusste ich:
Ich kann sie nicht mehr los lassen!È
ÇEs war einfach alles perfekt.
Es stimmte einfach alles.È
ÇWir hatten keine PlŠne.
Ich wollte einfach mit ihr sein ...
... und sie mit mir.
Lass uns heiraten!È
ÇIch war vier Jahre in Amerika.
Meine Tšchter wurden auch dort geboren.
Neomi besuchte dort
auch den Vorkindergarten, ...
... und in diesen vier Jahren
wurde mir bewusst, ...
... dass ich eigentlich nicht mšchte, ...
... dass meine Kinder so aufwachsen.È
ÇAls Eli sagte, sie mšchte wieder nach Hause, ...
... konnte ich das verstehen.
Es ging um die Familie. Und
die Ausbildung der Kinder.
Es ging auch um ihre Karriere.
Der wichtigste Punkt fŸr mich
war aber meine Anstellung.
Wie kann ich Ÿberleben?
Mein Deutschkenntnisse waren sehr begrenzt.
Also versuchte ich, ...
... mit meinem Arbeitgeber in den USA herauszufinden, ...
... ob ich einen internen Transfer ...
... in die Schweiz machen kann.
Und zum GlŸck funktionierte es!È
ÇWas ich sehr schnell gelernt habe, war:
Sei pŸnktlich!
Sei nicht eine Minute ...
... oder zwei Minuten zu spŠt!È
ÇDie Amerikaner nehmen es
nicht so genau.
Inzwischen bin ich schon Šhnlich.
Ich habe das GefŸhl, ich
komme auch immer zu spŠt.È
ÇWir haben uns entschieden,
zusammen zu sein.
Das bedeutet auch
die VermŠhlung von zwei Kulturen.
Ich trage die amerikanische Kultur in mir.
Das kann man nicht plštzlich abstellen.
Was ich tun kann, ist,
mich meiner Frau zu erklŠren.
Und wenn ich GlŸck habe,
hšrt und versteht sie mich.
Und dann sagt sie mir
auch ihre Meinung.
Und jetzt, wo wir in der Schweiz leben, ...
... muss ich mich anpassen.
Weil ...
... das ist mein Zuhause.
Meine Wurzeln sind in den USA, ...
... aber ich bin jetzt hier zuhause.
Also muss ich lernen, wie man hier lebt.È